cette semaine au cinéma le grenier à sel
nous vous proposons apocalypse now dans
une version directeur scott c'est à dire
que c'est une version qui a été
remasterisé le l'image et le son a été
remasterisé l'image et en ultra haute
définition 4k donc ça va bien en
profiter sur notre projecteurs sony 4k
et le son a été remis ces en cinq points
nous nous retrouvons ce sera donc le
vendredi 11 octobre à 20h45 au cinéma le
grenier à sel ce film apocalypse now est
un film c'est le film incroyable de
francis ford coppola qui nous embarque
dans la folie de la guerre du vietnam
mais la folie s'est aussi emparé du film
le tournage s'est éternisé dans la
jungle des philippines marlon brando
arrive sur le tournage il est obèse il
connaît pas son texte
l'acteur principal qui est martin sheen
il fait une crise cardiaque en plein
tournage et évidemment il ya plein
d'autres mésaventures sur la la
postproduction donc ce film qui sera le
vendredi 11 octobre à 20h45
il fait partie de programmation annuelle
de films de patrimoine le prochain
rendez-vous sera pour halloween avec
l'étrange noël de monsieur jack 2
novembre venez en famille et des visées
pour mettre de l'ambiance
[Musique]